quieres hacerle tus preguntas que
quieres hacer quieres ver al siguiente
chico muy bien veamos al siguiente chico
bien 10 contra 1 si te rápida con 10
chicos edición para mamás estás
emocionada si estás nerviosa le pedimos
a cali a que entrevistar a 10 chicos y
que escogiera una cita para su mamá
ariel
sientes que sabes lo que tu mamá quiere
en un chico sí y qué es eso
bondad amor
es un gran comienzo alguna vez has
intentado que los chicos salgan con tu
mamá
si recuerdas sientes que podrías elegir
una buena cita para tu mamá si sabes que
eso es lo que vas a hacer hoy sí
[Música]
primera ronda entrevistas lista para la
primera conversación
preparada para esto
hola soy y en hola bien encantado de
conocerte escuché que tienes preguntas
quisiera escucharla ahora es amable si
mis amigos creen que sí sí quizá sea la
persona más amable que conocerás soy muy
amable creo que sí soy amable
absolutamente puedo cocinar para ti qué
vas a cocinar sé hacer huevos
me encantan si podemos añadirle algo de
queso y tocineta me encantaría ayude a
esa persona sin hogar
hago lo que puedo es una pregunta
interesante lo hago me gusta alimentar a
las personas sin hogar y esas cosas si
vivo en vivo en los ángeles
hay muchos alrededor bien
hola hola mi nombre es nick soy cali a
ver si como va todo bien si como se
llama el tigre tics tics es un buen
nombre yo también tengo un pequeño y
hermoso oso se llama scooter
y quieres hacerle tus preguntas que
quieres hacer
quieres ver al siguiente chico muy bien
veamos al siguiente chico entendido fin
que tengas buen día qué te gusta hacer
por diversión
me gusta mucho nadar me gustó mucho
tocar mucha bien me gusta la música te
gusta cuál es tu artista favorito
willis ella es muy buena cierto aquel
lugar divertido te gustaría llevarnos si
te gustan los perros podríamos ir a la
playa de huntington beach tienen un día
en el que sólo hay corrigan císcar ha
sido alguna vez a parís hay un mercado
agrícola cerca de mi casa
creo que hay universal fui allí cuando
era un niño nunca he ido vamos ha sido
alguna vez a hawai nunca fui realmente
pero he ido a hawai pero no me quede
mucho tiempo cuando tenía tu edad mi
lugar favorito era legoland ya has ido
antes a legolas ya no definitivamente
iremos a nicolás díaz como lo hice esas
son todas las preguntas
primera ronda eliminación cálida debe
eliminar a seis personas de la cita
rápida
estaba muy nerviosa obviamente hoy no
fue un buen ejemplo pero diría que otras
veces me llevo muy bien con todos los
niños
[Música]
las niñas de 9 son inteligentes no dejes
que su nerviosismo te engañé ella sabe
exactamente lo que hace
[Música]
todo el mundo decía que creían que iba a
ganar y entonces me acerqué al frente
ella me sonrío muy lindo y luego me dijo
adiós y yo dije bien
yo estaba tan nervioso tratando de
hablar con la niña y leer su lenguaje
corporal si debía hacerle preguntas ese
tipo de interacciones son intimidantes
[Música]
segunda ronda cita con la mamá cada uno
de los cuatro chicos que quedan tiene un
minuto para hablar con ariel hola cómo
estás estoy bien soy ariel soy y han
encantado de conocerte tienes preguntas
para nosotras tengo curiosidad por el
cambio que pasó se acercó y dijo quiero
cambiar de opinión
genial tienes una hija increíble gracias
muy competente veo un gran reflejo de ti
tengo una pregunta para ella cuál es tu
color favorito
cambia cada día eres instrumentista
si yo toco el bajo profesional por
diversión por desgracia profesionalmente
entendido eres de aquí no nació en
oregón y estaba demasiado deprimido por
la lluvia de allí así que me mudé para
acá somos de washington conseguirlo
entendemos cuáles son tus pasatiempos me
gusta hacer vídeos de vídeos y audios o
vídeos de 'tik tok' lenguajes vídeos de
tipo puedes enseñar me estoy intentando
unir meticuloso trabajo en mi auto soy
mecánico puedo decir eso me gusta
construir cosas estoy haciendo un robot
en casa de papá hoy lo tiene cuáles son
sus pasatiempos nos encanta ir a la
playa al paseo marítimo de venice y
patinar y eso es genial segunda ronda
eliminación final
cali a debe eliminar a tres personas de
la cita rápida
[Música]
estoy muy contento de haber llegado a la
final pensé que el gorro ayudaría con la
niña y creo que lo hizo
[Música]
felicitaciones gane aún no ha terminado
ronda final 11 hola bienvenido de nuevo
gracias ella dijo podemos llevarlo a
casa en serio es algo si debo haber
causado buena impresión así seguro fue
el pelo que te gustó de la persona que
elegiste tiene buen aspecto y me gustó
su cabello hemos sido ella y yo desde el
primer día
ella me ruega por un padrastro todo el
tiempo de hecho normalmente su deseo de
cumpleaños así que sus hijos y que los
mírenla reírse por eso siempre me
resulta interesante lo que ella
considera importante sí estaba muy
centrado en cómo tratas a otras personas
se preocupa por asegurarse de que estás
con alguien que puede mostrar afecto por
extraños creo que es más sobre quién es
divertido para ella no necesariamente
sobre mi médico es todo lo que quiero
decir es mi plan era que si podía
ganármela tal vez gracias chicos sí
gracias
entonces digo gracias por mirar para
empezar y luego hago la pregunta y digo
gracias por mirar de nuevo y finalizó
con síguenos en estéreo speed eje de la
audiencia
sí sí exacto algo así bueno gracias por
mirar y asegúrate de seguirnos en
instagram o también puedes seguirme a mí
en instagram o puedes seguirle a ella en
instagram o puedes hacer lo que quieras
porque es tu decisión está bien si es
perfecto bien genial es el siguiente
jubilee vive intensamente